[Music]
There is nothing essentially stopping
this mosque from being built except that
lovers of freedom are not going to let
it happen. It ain't built yet. It ain't
over.
tenacity.
We have to never give up. We have to
have tenacity. And our next speaker is
one of the most remarkably tenacious and
courageous women I've ever been
privileged to know. Someone who was at
our June 6th rally or September 11th
rally, the Walmart protest. Everything
that she has, every time she has a
chance to stand for freedom, she does.
We should all imitate her. We should all
emulate her and we should all applaud
her. Vanelli Brigginski.
Thank you. Such a many good word about
me.
Friend
way you will be not here. If you're
here, you're the friends.
Uh it's 10 years already you know uh my
son I found out later he growing up in
New York I lived 32 years in New York he
graduated school college
and he went for meeting he was working
for Reuters
agency news and he went for meeting 8:30
and I watched In the morning time my
husband put news and I prepare myself go
to work and I yell on him I say why this
stupid movie in the early morning I have
to run and he says it's not movie say
come on
and when I saw this I have no idea what
my son also there but this is horrible
what I saw and I called to Reuters
nobody answer me nobody knows where is
Alex
and I cannot come to Reuters because uh
New York was close. I can tell you what
10 years I wear black not because of
religion but I believe the god but not
because of this.
I prepare evening time if I go somewhere
I will wear something else and come in
morning I open closet I wear black. I
cannot wear something else because
inside everything is black and all my
friends knows what I come in celebration
I say happy birthday I sing half hour
and I go because people dance people
happy I don't want to spo somebody's
mood on this and now
uh about politics it's unbelievable
because we meet all the time politic
four September 11. Uh, forgive my
English, it's not so perfect. I'm from
Russia. And, uh, Russian group have a
memorial in Brooklyn in the park. Uh,
government from the city give us five m
to put tree and we put tree and we put
small memorial and we came together to
this place talking about our children
before September 11. Believe me all
politic from Brooklyn is there all of
them but nobody open mouth what happened
this story with mask they come in took
picture and they left
finish never again and first who told
about uh politic
microphone
okay I can talk without mic microphone.
I have a working. Okay. Uh you know uh
first it was our mayor Bloomberg and I
never forget this. He said it's not
politic. It's a constitution. Tell me
what this constitution. Constitution let
everybody believe the god. America
all America it's immigrant. Thank you
this country when they let us come in.
We can work. Our children can go to
school, get education, continue to build
this country. Where is Politica? You
want to pray? Pray. Everybody pray to
the God. Usually in a church, in a
synagogue, in any place when they pray
or at home, why only Muslims stay on the
street? 500 people stay on the knee, put
down and they have to pray on the
street. What is this? uh demonstration
I met Mrs. Di k I don't remember p this
yes wife of the imam it was in the queen
college what my son graduate and I
didn't know nobody told me I open in
queen college uh conference room I give
money for scholarship uh for books for
everything but nobody told me what we'll
be meeting Mrs. Daisy have a lecture and
name of this lecture was to build or not
to build. See educated woman
and when she finish everything I stand
up they try not let me to talk. I said
guys I will talk.
You will not close. Shut up my mouth. I
will. And I came on the floor over here
in the middle of the row and I say
forgive me I will stay by my side you
but I want to see eyes this lady I say
you have a kids yes you know if uh wife
pass away
men you call widow no wife is widow man
is
uh when mother lost child
maybe you know English word I don't No
maybe because I don't know such a
perfect English no word for this what
mother lost child it's all life is the
finish life is finished just finish we
live I believe what I talk for every
mother we walk we doing everything but
it's normal life finish I have only one
son no grandchildren nothing finished
and when I start to talk to Mrs. visit
and I start to tell her I said listen
it happens I have nothing against of
Muslim I never think about this so many
people live in United States everything
is fine everybody go to church pray any
everything I said why why in this plane
what killed 3,000 American was no
Italian no German no Russian no Romanian
everybody was Muslim why this happened
and she was quiet. I said tell me why
these people dance. I saw by my eyes in
K Island in Brooklyn they dance. I think
somebody from you also saw this. They
dance, they celebrate, they give you
also they give a candy to children and
you know about this lady answer me I
didn't know this I have no chance to
talk to parents and to whom you talk if
not to family to whom you're talking she
has no chance she came to wash brain to
the student that's it I say you know
Mrs. Daisy, I would like to see your
husband. I want to look in his eyes,
mate. I know men from uh east, they
cannot say that they lost something.
They win. They winner. They have to be
winner. I say I will help him. I will go
with him to uh radio, to TV, to all
over. I will help him to do this daily.
I promise you, I'm going for a few days
to India to see my mom and after that I
will let you see my husband. both of
them disappear.
Now they travel around and talking uh
build or not to build.
And I told her I said listen this what
you want to do. It's memorial for people
who kill 3,000 American. It's not only
mask. I don't believe you. I travel a
lot and I saw many many masks in the
many many Muslim country. I didn't see
13th floor. Why you need 13th floor
prepare new killers in this place?
Because you cannot send anymore check
and a plane. It's difficult on this
place. You can do everything. It's sport
is swimming pool. You can teach them
this memorial. It's your style to do
this. I believe what this is truth and
uh Bloomberg said what this is uh they
have they can do everything what they
want and know politic shut up not one
open mouth I have nothing to lose I lost
everything
you rest of the people your children
your grandchildren have to be alive
somebody uh knows for sure what uh
tomorrow Tonight, next day something,
God forbid, not happen in a bridge, in a
uh metro,
restaurant, any place, a mediot will
come in and blowing up. Nobody knows
what will be.
And I believe what all of you knows what
told um premier minister of England, his
name is James Cameroon. Yes. And he told
absolutely truth. He told what first of
all people who give money have to check
be careful for what they give money
where from this money come in he was
right don't give place to extremist
have a speech don't do this he was right
everything what he says is right uh now
I ask guys journalist who works for TV
maybe we can ask premier minister from
England, Mr. James maybe when come in uh
in United Nation or another place before
it was eight country now it's already
201 12 uh guys premier minister our b
was Mr. Obama maybe he will give this
proposition to everybody. Maybe
everybody start to talk. Obama didn't
say anything. He has a children also.
Uh
I don't know. Uh Mr. Obama was in the
east and he put down his head front of
king or who was this Muslim guy? Yeah.
What is this? I think what president
country as a United States don't have to
put down his head a front of anybody.
I think like this
and a few more words. All immigrant who
came here
it mean they feel bad in the country
when they was leave. It was so good they
were so happy they never come here but
they came here it's they supposed to
came here. Why they want to change
everything here? They want to make from
us Muslim. They never will be Muslim.
From me, from you, from everybody.
Tomorrow they will like St. Peter
Cathedral and make a mask in St. Peta.
Have to do something.
Everybody from you can do something. I
believe what this mask never will be.
Never. If we have to stay a front of
this building, we will stay at night.
All of us.
[Applause]
It bears note it bears noting two
things. Rahul Daisy Khan and Sharif
Agamal were invited to this event. They
could have named the format any way, any
shape or form. Uh they refused to come.
That's the first thing. And the second
thing is the first imam is gone. The
second imam is gone. They've raised no
money. Don't think that we're not making
a difference. We're making it very very
hard for them. That's not an accident.